these days they're going to take it all
these places and then they can be three
minutes - that's true that's what
they've been doing we haven't gone
anywhere but every time we stop they
take us to a store that's virtually
empty until we show up even that
restaurant that we had was virtually
empty and you're pretty smart you know
what you know what all right panting
I'll see you I'll see you I'll see you
I'll see okay you messed it up people
who are left-handed will probably do
with their left hand with the percentage
of that we were having a good moment but
I fall into it I've have it all figured
out and I'm sewing to spend money did
you genius
these guys are gonna try to scam us oh
my god where's it's so good news so I
asked our tour guide and this trip isn't
really lost because we're gonna be
riding a pirate ship yeah in the phony
what are you gonna do Josh and we were
gonna have a biochip you don't even know
oh you don't say without smiling what
was you gonna do murder everyone dad
why you're in Suva guys enjoyed azimuth
so you know you're hurting yeah
are you excited for the pirate-ship yeah
you go push you right now one two
too late haha you missed it again I'm
ready I'm ready
I know I consistently give you desert
yeah they push me I know I can are you
know I give you two chances this year no
I gave you two chances it's red
oh you're gonna punch him can I record
it I want in the face of the chest do it
with all your might and put your body
into it like an you swing why don't we
give it like I promised
right on right hood use your back leg to
describe a joke three okay
she's been waiting for this moment all
day I don't like all sex with
my nose is sweating wise moist
can you tell right now I felt like that
was only 16 percent see this I'm
throwing gang signs at you put my whole
arm is dead why don't you go a hundred
percent oh no what you missed you get my
soul
good job Julia I wouldn't do it again
what happened why did you ate him a
punch I don't know no good to get he
kept using a face when you told her to
do it it's gonna bring that is whether
than come here I think you would touch
me so hard you hit my grandpa dude a
grandpa in the grave like over the phone
oh you're strong I have no worries about
you ever getting raped and I know
we are on this pirate ship and it's
moving right now it feels interesting I
have no idea what a pirate ship has to
do with like Japanese culture but I'm
pretty sure the word that I'm looking
for is nothing very nostalgic because I
came to this country this way now
Michael the [ __ ] model do
getting sexy with everybody Michael show
them show them right there you you shown
that playing great sputter there you go
that barbell Brigade yes right yes my
shoulder we got a caller on the way we
turn you must decide wisely [ __ ] I know
exactly how that's going
hey I'm looking to see anything I'm just
saying Mike my skinny Japanese [ __ ]
I just want to eat actually first and uh
I've been just eating in chilla I don't
want to take no place out haha back to
our crib smile yeah we'll get your bone
our heroine lotus-eyed okay just don't
I'm not running by the way if I really
look like quintessential what they say
like the spot touch the boots I call
Raman IKEA the equivalent to a sandwich
to my person so I could be wrong in my
own life but so I'm super excited to eat
this a lot of the other one places I I'm
not sure if ahead like a super
authenticity because if you guys
remember on the first in time we went to
a place that we're actually all my
Chinese people and then we kinda got
[ __ ] over by that right here
I think one of the bet with the biggest
difference between ones that we've had
in like la the beach one not a pork one
speaker it should be prodigy it tastes
like that I mean I thought Korean
oxtails yes I love that this is what it
kind of tastes good
it's um sometimes the oxtail soup tastes
like it's just like that you have a
crazy sweet tooth you like do you prefer
desserts over savory things yeah that's
blasphemous that's blasphemous this dirt
is so Bob that Brandon rarely likes
young brothers a Montessori enjoys it we
[ __ ] loved it you know Cal be right
make the potato chips yeah freshly fried
here uh-huh
they give you a vanilla soft serve hot
fudge and it's the weirdest combination
but it works you know what I hate sweet
if I don't like this brand I'm gonna get
bark to [ __ ] you in the acid you guys
give me I got you glass yeah [ __ ] I
wanna get what that tastes like boy what
a day my boy go go go go whoo why your
whole hand okay
ten day roll
is there anyone in the Japanese before
there is any more cleaning on here don't
ever do that Isaac
we're back at the house after a long day
yeah we went back and got some food
again so we had an experience the other
night where we had a fruit from this
Japanese market it's like this corner
market right out the subway and every
time what every time we went there last
time and so we came back Joe bought some
more fruit and they actually hooked it
up so we're gonna try some more fruit
pretty expensive those are $23 Wadden
hood for crying out loud but I'm pretty
sure it'll be worth it because a great
sight we had yesterday it was pretty fun
today was a fun day the tour was a
little bit off but yeah man day two is a
success so day three CEO